anger and frustration in eswatini
the crowds built barricades and burned
tyres despite an overnight curfew
and what the opposition's calling a
tipping point for the nation
demonstrations like this are rare in the
small landlocked country
formerly known as swaziland but descent
has been simmering for years
much of it focused on king amswati
africa's last
absolute monarch and one of the few
remaining in the world
ladies and gentlemen his majesty
the king of swaziland
he was crowned in 1986 aged just 18
and has unfettered political power he
has 15
wives and has been criticized for his
lavish spending
while most in iswatini live in poverty
we are the youth of switzerland and we
are so much depressed
by the government gangster ramos
whichever time except
our government is not being failed you
get me
our government is not being fair it's
just once it's just a one
the protesters say they want democracy
political parties are banned
and even though people are allowed to
vote for members of parliament
the opposition says they're not
elections more selections
of people signed off by the king us as
young people of the land
we don't want the king to be part of the
government and if we want to be part of
the government
he must first be a citizen like the rest
of us and go to work like every one of
us
some shops in its two biggest cities
have been looted
and others set on fire the military's
been out to enforce a curfew which the
government says is to ensure the safety
and security of residents
[Music]
but the opposition says some protesters
have been killed
and many others wounded the acting prime
minister says
he's open to hearing the people's
complaints but demonstrating
isn't the way to do it we're a nation
that believes in dialogue government has
opened
an email address where maswati can
continue to direct their concerns and
petitions
for decades king amswati has been
portrayed as a deeply popular monarch
now the government's been forced to deny
reports he's fled to the country
his kingdom appears to be in crisis alex
o'brien al jazeera